so crypto prices
i mean
what the hell is going on bitcoin is
down 50
since the high in november it wasn't 69
000 nice and now it has dropped all the
way down uh bitcoin currently sitting
around 33 000 give or take uh there's a
whole bunch of different things going on
first of all over the last two years
what we saw was a fed induced massive
bull market what i mean by that the
federal reserve uh and elected officials
they stepped in with monetary stimulus
and they pushed asset prices up they
mitigated short-term pain at the cost of
long-term pain ultimately what that
drove was everything from a price
standpoint went up that includes
investments in stocks real estate
commodities bitcoin etc but also in
consumable goods and so when you see
inflation at eight and a half percent
officially in the united states seven
and a half percent in europe and
elsewhere ultimately what that tells you
is that the price of everything went up
and so naturally we all focus on
consumables but of course investments
went up as well so my rich people like
inflation they're making money now the
fed says whoa whoa prices went up too
high we got overextended it got too hot
up in here nelly and so naturally what
they're going to have to do is they're
going to bring those prices down the way
that they do that is they basically have
two main tools the first is they say we
are going to raise interest rates
previously we cut them now we're going
to increase the interest rates they went
ahead and first did a 25 basis point
raise they added in a 50 basis point
raise in the last two weeks now we're at
0.75
and so naturally they continue to raise
interest rates and people say wow
capital is getting more and more
expensive maybe i'm not going to go
borrow as much maybe i'm not going to
actually spend as much as i thought i
was so naturally the
expensiveness of the capital leads to
prices coming down also on top of that
the federal reserve has been the
persistent buyer in the market they've
been buying all sorts of different
assets as they go into a period of
quantitative tightening the opposite of
quantitative easing the quantitative
tightening period will mean that the fed
does not actually buy a lot of those
assets they begin to taper either they
slow down their buying or they
completely stop buying and so when that
occurs one of the strongest most
important persistent buyers in the
market disappears if capital becomes
more expensive and the federal reserve
at the same time is no longer a
persistent buyer in the market
nationally prices have to come down now
over time what the fed is ultimately
trying to do is get inflation from eight
and a half percent in united states down
to two percent that two percent
inflation rate is their target but if
they want the cost of goods and services
for the average person to come down from
eight and a half to two percent guess
what comes down with it also the price
of investments and so naturally we are
seeing these sophisticated folks on wall
street or in financial markets they are
selling assets or they are not buying as
many of them as they previously were
because they anticipate that asset
prices will continue to go down bitcoin
down 50 is that a big deal well bitcoin
now has been down 50
four times in the last four years so
this isn't necessarily something new but
it is something to be aware of because
whether we like it or not bitcoin nasdaq
correlations at or near all-time highs
and the fed is in control the fed is the
boss don't fight the fed if the fed is
going to tell you we're going to get
loose around here that means get long
and get loud if they say we're going to
get tight around here that means maybe
you don't want to hold assets and maybe
you should just chill out make the fed
sound like a dj at a nasty nightclub the
fed is in control like the fed there is
there is there is no free market in the
legacy financial world anymore if the
fed says we are going to ease asset
prices explode when the fed says we are
going to tighten asset prices come down
the fed is the sale be all in financial
markets they basically are playing god
at this point and if you're an investor
you can fight the fed or you can just do
what they say to do and that's
ultimately what's going to determine
what your financial return is yep all
right next all right you know rivian yes
electric vehicle startup that was once
hot
ford motor is selling eight million of
its rivien automotive shares as the
insider lock up for the stock expired
yesterday
that's not really a vote of confidence
is it
i don't think that uh people should be
surprised by this at all well because
why because of riven's troubles have you
seen most of these electric vehicles
that are coming either from the legacy
manufacturers or some of these startups
they basically just took a regular car
right and they just made it
yeah they just made it electric and
they're like oh we have this electric
vehicle the beauty of uh
tesla as the leader in the electric
vehicle market is that they reimagined
the entire car they don't even think of
it as a car it's a computer on wheels
and when you sit in one what you realize
is this is different there aren't all
the little knobs and all the little
buttons there's no volume there's no oh
shut the radio on or off let me press
this button oh there's a light where's
the heat uh the uh seat heater none of
that stuff is going on what they did is
they reimagined the entire experience
including things like the roof the roof
is on fire the roof is glass right and
so when you start to think about this
that is why they're the leaders because
they're a true innovator everyone else
is playing ketchup and a company like
rivian
if you're a ford you know you can't play
uh uh the market via tesla so you go to
rivian and then you rise eventually
somewhere along the way like ah this
might not be as good of an investment as
we thought and i think i think it's more
expensive obviously to start from
scratch like tesla did so what are these
other startups trying to do they're like
oh that's like
it'll be a little bit cheaper if we just
like refurbish the car instead of start
over
of course and look tesla did the hard
work like that's the other pieces they
thought really long term and they did
the hard work now some people may not
like the financials of the business they
may not like elon musk whatever but at
the end of the day what they did is they
did the hard work of creating a car
company from scratch which allowed them
to reimagine both the car and also the
monetization the charging network etc
all from first principles and that tends
to be a better long-term solution than
making micro kind of improvements to an
existing system that is not built for
the future it is interesting we uh just
watched this documentary on netflix
called um what was it called spacex and
their launch when they launched the uh
humans uh into uh the iss right
but what's interesting is that like
tesla and spacex i guess um they're just
like
there aren't close second like rivals no
they're true disrupters there there's
not a it's not an uber uh uber lyft type
situation this is why uh all of the hate
that elon musk gets is so stupid is
because
building one of these companies is yeah
yeah building building a
true solution from first principles is
very difficult and expensive
incredibly expensive
he has done it now multiple times and
not only has he done it multiple times
but he's done it with such a track
record of success uh both from an
execution standpoint and also a final
product if you go and you sit in a tesla
and then you go sit in another car
you're like duh this one's better yeah
and so naturally what ends up happening
is there's a lot of fast followers
there's a lot of people who try to
compete but it always goes back to if
you've ever seen the michael phelps meme
where michael phelps is in first and
there's somebody in second and michael
phelps is looking forward and the second
place is looking at michael phelps and
it's first place is focused on the
future the second place is worried about
the first place and that's what's
happening in these markets well that's
fair um i just just the small aside i
saw this hilarious meme speaking of cars
about how like it was like oh everybody
says that today's drivers are so
distracted and then the meme was this
guy driving in like the late 90s and he
was flipping through his like cd case
trying to like find the right cd he
opens up map quests tries to like see
where he's at so good that is exactly
what people were doing you've ever seen
uh where they compare people on uh i
think it's the bus or the subway and uh
now everyone's got their heads down into
their phones but it used to be with the
newspapers and i missed that the more
things change the more they stay the
same
yeah i guess all right now there's it's
there's something about the the paper
and the in the folding no and then and
then you no have you ever seen somebody
try to figure out how to refold the
paper oh my god there's a science
okay
to save
itself
netflix might have to partner
with movie theaters but there's a big
battle and debate about how long like
let's say a netflix original can be
at a movie theater and they can't really
i think this is a horrible idea well
they're trying to find solutions their
stock is plunging well maybe they should
do one of two things stop going woke and
obviously people will stick around more
and then the second thing i would say is
they probably should focus on
going more user-generated content i i've
always thought for a long time that
generated content yeah netflix similar
to youtube should say what we are going
to allow you to do is reduce the
friction for getting your video onto
netflix uh i don't know here's why
because if i as an individual
want to go and watch
professionally done stuff right i go to
netflix but if they had a section that
was like up and coming and the up and
coming section was anyone in the world
could create documentaries etc they
could submit it to netflix
netflix did not pay them for it at first
or there was some sort of advertising
model they essentially would then they
would be able to get way more content on
there what do you and i
watch
on
the internet
we watch youtube and it's usually longer
form videos there's interviews there's
all this stuff like that
phineas yes so he a great example there
he makes these documentaries they're not
high quality enough to go and sell to
netflix
but they are entertaining enough and
high quality enough if they had a
user-generated section and let the end
users decide but on top of that imagine
if all of those youtube uh documentaries
that people make etc you could
essentially upload it netflix keeps
[ __ ] so much more content behind
their paywall and be off to the races
here's the problem there's all sorts of
like rights and like you can't just do
that like
netflix has certain
partnerships and like copyright issues
and bull you can't just like be like oh
here you go they solved it already who
did netflix how
they whatever gets listed they figured
it out who has the copyright who owns
this who does this whatever
it's a massive business
i don't know part of it is you gotta
solve this free idea netflix but um do
you wanna guess what is the
most
watched movie ever on netflix the most
watched movie ever on netflix i don't
know what is it you're gonna be
surprised by this
maybe i won't red notice with dwayne the
rock johnson and ryan reynolds yeah that
is
i thought it was such a cheesy movie but
you know i love the rock
can't say nothing bad and ryan i didn't
think it would be the most popular movie
on netflix but it makes sense the rock
is the number one most recognizable
actor in the world and so my guess is
that it over indexes compared to most
movies international and that would make
sense as to how it becomes the number
one
all right next all right ready
so
you know calm the meditation and
wellness company is looking for a voice
that will put people to sleep and it's
going to pay you 5 000 if you're the
winner with the most soothing voice to
record one of calm's upcoming sleep
stories
hello oh god
close your eyes this is how i go to
sleep every night guys
start to care about the sheep that are
jumping over the gate that's not what
how many people dropped out because they
fall asleep five
i'm just saying hey five thousand
dollars i'm out though my voice
i have a voice of an angel it is worth
way more than five thousand dollars
4.2 billion you can offer at least 10k
come on
oh okay uh paulina
the accountant
i have a very how do you know that
they're not actually going to end up
paying out hundreds of thousands of
dollars but he's personally it's one
entrant oh that's i think or a one can
whatever all right next
where are we
sophia sophie no giraffe no no it goes
sophie legit
[Music]
what what is this oh wait i don't have
it with me you know the giraffe the
other day that he had here with him
sophia's giraffe it's actually called
sophie it is sophie
la
what i took french is that french yes
it's french yes so i got i got problems
with the french this this giraffe was
no mako no oh god sorry guys i just
apologize in advance for everything i
got good ass food though so is that
where crepes come from
yes the fresh invisible crepes no crepe
yeah
that whole uh how they pronounce works
great hey i'm american correct i
pronounce it the american way but you
put some nutella on a crepe i'm in let
me just tell you guys something when i
took french
at georgia
all these kids with these southern
accents trying to pronounce french words
i was like
anyway all right what's up with this
i hope my french teacher's prep people
are saying i'm on culture don't you all
don't understand my culture let me try
to take my culture
see one person said bravo
do you know what that means i have no
clue what that means so pretty
thank you the only french i know comes
from a song that i'm not going to repeat
see i'm so good
i'm so good at french somebody asked if
i was anyone that's in like the late 20s
early 30s you all know what i'm talking
about
i'm i'm just saying what what is it how
do you say it no then you can be like
y'all know what i'm talking about go
ahead so anyway sophia
in 1961 1961 this giraffe's been around
yes it was launched in 1961 in france
and the toy originally was made manually
using rubber and food-based paint and
today millions are sold every year in 85
countries um so this is the single
best-selling kids toy in the world
i i don't know but let me just tell you
something
a regular teether like one of those
rubber things that babies chew on for
their teeth costs like five dollars this
one costs 27.
okay but well it looks okay
well and it's french that just they
immediately tax you because it's french
never been to a french restaurant
they're like oh by the way the
ingredients don't make me 20 meal it's
30 here so why we're french
unfortunately i the only articles around
was like from 2012 i couldn't find
anything recent but the company behind
it had sales of 29 million dollars and
since
then that's not that much
wait what 29 million that was in 2012
okay
and that's when they were expanding
outside of france and they were
expecting
to have more sales outside of france
since then and i bet you i mean all
these like celebrities have this like
this giraffe is everywhere it's in
bulgaria like it's insane i don't think
it's that much oh my god it's so much
and let me tell you why it's popular
hold on i texted you this yesterday and
now i'm trying to find it it says the
ceo hired a psychotherapist who
concluded the rubber chew toy tapped
into all five senses sight with the
contrasting colors hearing with the easy
squeak taste because you can eat it and
the touch and smell of the natural
rubber look i feel like that's like
every other toy
should i get in the giraffe game
i'll take on the french
the called the french revolution oh man
i bet you i could outsell them
i think we first should people are
asking if i'm an investor in the biz i
ain't an investor in the french giraffe
you should have been no the american
giraffe will outsource the french
giraffe the american draft will be
called like barney or something no we'll
just no we won't say it in a weird way
we'll just say giraffe okay we can say
bachni
[Laughter]
by the way
i'm sitting up here laughing i'm joking
around that giraffe has saved my ass
like six times if the giraffe's around
and sophia is crying i i'm already i'm
good
i washed it because it fell on the floor
and anthony was like i gave it back to
him and he was like where did the squeak
go he was like if he doesn't squeak then
we got problems he goes it's okay sophia
i'll buy you a new one like no you won
it's 27 dollars 127 speaking of
inflation that isn't uh that doesn't
squeak the squeaker was not worth
another investment of 27 dollars girl
you don't have to figure it i just i
just when you squeeze it all yell
all right let's go are they looking for
voice voice actors for squeaky toys okay
ask lunch
okay from jerry perez
ready
i'm glad you guys are back me too super
excited me too okay but to the question
what do you think it will take to start
the next bull run
i think that there's three things that
are going to be needed one is you're
gonna have to have the fed go on ice
and the fed by the end of the year i
think will go on ice but let's see what
happens uh so they're gonna have to stop
hiking interest rates they're gonna have
to say ooh
recession is here maybe we should go
ahead and we should actually enter into
uh
some sort of quantitative easing period
again um so that'll get you two of the
things and the third thing is uh likely
met with some sort of catalyst
from either a big buyer a big announcer
or something so you need the right macro
environment at this point and then
you're going to need a catalyst those
are two things and inside of the macro
environment you're going to need them to
chill on increasing interest rates and
you're also going to need them to go
ahead
and
start quantitative easing again but to
me that's going to be the uh the big
thing and go on ice what i mean by that
is
you're going to need them to stop
raising interest rates you're going to
stop quantitative tightening
because you basically need to
create an environment where asset prices
can appreciate
uh but as long as you're fighting the
fed which right now bitcoin is fighting
the fed
not so hot not so good so we're gonna
have to uh we're gonna have to change
that up a little bit i
all right anything else anything else
you got there pulling up on somebody
said something interesting and now i
lost it all right well
we don't move on unless you can find it
in the next like one two all right
bye guys
hey by the way happy mother's day uh day
two thank you also i just want to say on
the air that john i found out gave him
the idea for my mother's day gift john
me like you know we were on the show
together we were we were brainstorming
we forget who actually came up with the
idea but like yeah we're good for
mother's day
am i a good mother's day gifter
yes
nice cool all right thank you so much
see you tomorrow